right okay
well good morning counselors and ladies
ladies and gentlemen
um
welcome to this uh internal scrutiny uh
that we'll show you um
and
on this lovely spring light day so
we'll get on straight on with it so we
can go ahead and enjoy it i think
um
apologies for absence first
apologies from councillor watson with
councillor leather substituting
anthropologies from council of baltimore
and councillor pumpkin right thank you
no other apologies
no okay
moving on to the minutes in
of the last meeting
which was on the 8th of february
i'll go through them page by page the
page number at the top
that's page 1
[Music]
h2
page three
page four
page five
page six
thank you okay
um
types of harding seconded all those in
favor
okay
goes against
extensions
thank you for that
all right move on to item
four
now the action this sorry item three
um which is on page ten
i only got one there
one three three
and that's complete
everybody okay with that
yes
right move on to
item four public contributions
don't think we have any
no
um declarations of interest where you
all know
the score there i think by now
if you have anything you can check out
now or when we go along
in the agenda okay
right moving on to urgent matters
brought forward
by the chair i have none
i think steve has no chair
all right good
um
agreement agenda parts item one and two
we have no part two items
as such at the moment
um
so we move on now to the
[Music]
[Music]
this is like you've got three section
council's performance
position the end of december
2021 just going into a few highlights of
that report
and first of all on
team one local economy
um today in november swedish pokeball
meeting news opened at the new polar
bear center
we had another thousand businesses sign
up for the new northern devon discovery
launch in november
and toyota was the highest in the
district national
[Music]
so that's part of our goal to keep our
community local businesses going and do
this for the council would pay on time
i think at the last pbr2 somebody asked
about
our wage levels in college and whether
it be impact last year i just got the
figures now for 2021.
this looks
um waiting times over the last five
years since people actually work within
the district
and you'll see last year with actually a
10.5 increase
um you know wage levels locally that's
really a combination of a lot of um
shortages in the hospitality sector and
also the year before they've actually
fallen four percent so a bit of a
collection as well
[Music]
um she wanted to make out that at the
bottom there was still 21 below the
national level so we're still a low-wage
economy in college but there was a quick
change last year because of the shortage
of anti-sector driving of wages
and theme two is the
community housing housing
[Music]
uh the first one now we actually have a
billion
[Music]
[Music]
this is the um time the domestic abuse
training kind of security safety
partnership
and
we're going to need some improvements
and new home divisions so the actual
planning is being happening actually our
building properties now because of
districts which obviously dropped off
because encoded
accommodation rising
and we have a staff of duty to actually
house people who are homeless
and you may have seen this craft
recently but
um
you'll see over the last kind of six
seven quarters we've seen a very small
increase each quarter of people
who are actually quite homeless another
last kind of six months it's actually
almost doubled
so
a lot of pressure there on the housing
team
there's actually a lack of mental
properties which are suitable and then
some increasingly russian using their
houses for holiday let's airbnbs
and obviously people who've got
poisonous industries actually
lack of opportunities
and there's a lot of issue um
initiatives across the council at the
moment towards the housing side going on
and you know this shows that is actually
housing classes at the moment in college
it's happening basically
moving on to the environment
thing three
and
council value disposable british
buildings which was a very um energy
efficient inefficient building
i thought i heard here that we actually
set off she's objective active college
but this was kind of in december and
lastly it's going to give you an update
on the leisure services uh contracts and
everything later on because we actually
got live next friday the first of april
so
and and recycling weeks actually last
year was our best of the year and that's
just even higher so we're still creeping
up the recycling level which is a great
achievement in college
um
this one here just to comment upon the
new environmental center progressing
slowly um
this was in december has been some steps
forward in the last few months so i've
been in qbr4 we'll see some
design and everything but we're still a
couple years off it's actually being
delivered
and just out of interest here
um
some figures on that electric charging
points vehicles and torch
as you'll see from that's our benchmark
family how we compare
the black line is actually district
average so we are
slightly above the actual average for
providing
electric charging points for vehicles
but if you're looking in terms of
home change home charge devices
especially what's with the table so
i think that reflects our low-wage
economy that many ways electric cars are
still seen as a kind of middle class
and nice to have rather than an
essential commodity at the moment for
people who tends affordability
and finally thing for our council
the website live in october which is a
long time ago now and it was very
successful
the planning team actually
asked him as an ecg and it's actually 90
higher this year
um
massive volumes
[Music]
but the good news is actually still
achieving uh service standards a magical
sense of creation develop depending on
time so
obviously one small planning team
in in the face of human huge work
volumes
i just want that just uh the downside is
that we still see an impact on our cars
tax and business rate collection levels
were still gone last year
the still impacts of code as a local
community
just a final graph here for interest is
this is actually
people who are self-employed
and see what actually the toys rushing
double the national level in terms of um
self-employed people
against people who paid employment
normally so ahead of the second private
seems a very healthy side the local
economy but this only was hit quite
heavily by kovid so again there's more
problems for our local economy
i was going to pass on to david
jones
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
i'll just go through the financial
aspects of the qbi3
the first slide you see in front of you
is our income
and as you can see my column blindness
will get me again but everything in
green is above target now so the only um
one that's particularly below target is
the harbor and pilotage
um
so with regards to our salaries uh we do
have an issue in the council at the
moment
and we're actually disrupting to build
vacancies um
and the time between building vacancies
is also expensive to go after a
so
and understand on our salary budget i
wouldn't say that necessarily is a good
news story i'd say that more of a
challenge and actually more of an
indication of difficult times that we're
actually in
apologies
so
[Music]
on this slide i've listed the major
underspends i only really want to focus
on it through the top
there's a chris has alluded to our plan
team we've had a exceptional year again
in terms of the volume of applications
now we're actually forecasting the
budget to be 645 000 above the budget
when the budget is about six hundred
thousand that's giving you mapping to
what we're facing it's actually double
again
uh one of the great contributing factors
to our darling spend is that new burdens
grant funding we've received from
central government with respect to all
the various work that we've done in
response to the pandemic primarily
business support grounds but also other
things such as household crisis funds
track and trace payments and that's
generated 380 000 pounds and thank you
to the council
and to a large degree apart from every
discretionary act we've largely absorbed
that within existing resources a little
bit of all time a little bit of agency
staff
but to a large degree that's just been a
burden upon the existing workforce and
robotic largely the same existing
workforce in the
uh business rates team and finance
department
salary understands 160 165 66 000 above
thousand sex that's actually 466 000.
so
that yes he's contributed financially
somebody's going out the council's
coffers but just means there's less
bombs on sea very simplistically
and uh that's a bit of a challenge for
the council and an increasing one
cardboard in income with the borrowers
that's a combination of the increased
charges and also the extended time that
the uh charging for access to the
borrowers
um i would like ten for to go through
every last one one that's on that list i
just want to go through the highlights
i'm gonna
on here these are the
overspend so ignore everything at the
bottom in green because that's
contributions to reserve us because
because of understand we can set money
aside to resist i'll come back to that
later
i really would like to focus on the
first item at the top which comes on a
theme that's um
crystallinity earlier
we've got to show up we've actually have
shot for the house and then he's fit so
today for two reasons primarily
homelessness but there's another country
which is backed up
as he has chris alluded to there
previously he showed the increase in the
number of um
households within temperature
accommodation and the way the housing
system works in very simple terms
councils are penalized for having people
in terms of accommodation the incentive
is not to have people in of acquisition
which is a
goal
i think most people would agree is
correct
so
the government doesn't want people to
put the councils for people in terms of
accommodation to be fully met that those
costs from housing management subsidy
and have no real incentive then to move
them on into sustainable tendencies
well that goal is worthy in its own
right however the consequence of the
moment is
there's a chris mentioned with a charge
but
accommodation we can move people on to
so we're getting more people coming to
the council looking for help with
homelessness
and we've got less capacity to deal with
it because it's less rented
accommodation available to them which
means the numbers increase in temporary
accommodation and the cost of the
council increasing in terms of lost
housing rented subsidy
roughly every single night that somebody
spends in temporary accommodation costs
the council over 45 pounds per night and
that varies from the time of year in the
summer that'll be significantly higher
because
holiday accommodation isn't available to
us like caravans etc
and it'll also mean that we have to
house people further away from the
boundaries of torridge
that 207 000 basically
came into
was highlighted in the last quarters
christie's grasshog very stark increase
in the number of people contemporary
accommodation
i do worry about what that figure will
be this time next year
i also point out that's 207 thousand
above budget we're already budget in
that currency to have a cost of two
hundred thousand a shot of house event
so that is actually a cost to the
council of 400 some pounds i can easily
see that figure being in the 500 to 750
000 pound cost to the council
next year
and unless there's a change in let's be
truthful is it change unless it changes
housing benefits substitute rules
there's very little the council can do
to mitigate this the council cannot
create overnight
senate accommodation that's not within
our power
our capacity
so that's the one thing that well i'll
say keeps me sleepless at night sleep
well in fairness but that's the one
thing that is of concern
this housing medical services shop we
haven't captured that in our budget
setting so i mentioned when we did the
budgets
this last time internal security full
council cnr etc
uh all the pressures of council
basically that is a new and emerging
pressure that this council is facing
um
i've already obviously i think most of
the others have alluded to in previous
um meetings
there's anything particularly new that's
come about there
um in terms of the excess pay well
that's been just a good budgeting wrong
following government guns
more for only um doing that
down at the bottom in highlighted in
green
the first branch there's what we've
already agreed to put society reserved
so previously from the surplus reported
quarter two
recognizing the difficulties we have in
recruitment and trying to grow our own
and recognize whether in some ways an
aging workforce and trying to plan for
that and then 600 into the transition
government fund in brazil which is our
builder science account of balancer
books
and cnr on the 14th of march recommended
the utilization of the increase in the
surplus from quarter two to quarter
which is about 318 000
and i've summarized it though there's
160 contributions to capital his
contribution to economic development and
training 65 000 various one-off grant
supports the various
[Music]
organizations and a household in funding
support of 38 000.
so
what that slide is showing that is you i
should have really put something in
essence
[Music]
we've underspent by 1.2 million we're
putting 1.2 million various guys into
reserves
[Music]
i've already talked about this slide so
it's not quite caring i've already give
you the
yeah that i've mentioned it's about the
planning income
so the next slide capital
and the thing that stands out there of
course is we've got we've been property
and infrastructure and nine million
pound capital budget and we've spent
four hundred and forty twelve seven
million of that is the environmental
center
and there's actually a slight title says
the project is expected to stand this
financially i think i should say the
project is not expected to start in this
financial apologies for that
um i've not particularly got much else
to say on the capital uh other than
obviously we've put extra into the
budget to take into account uh
construction price inflation and again
the difficulty of actually getting
people to actually tender for works
i'm showing this slide it's not slightly
unchanged from
quarter two but just to emphasize when
we're talking about the council's airman
reserves
you've got the best part of
4.8 million there which are it says some
total of the revenue reserves and that's
basically technical issues where
to do the business rate and to do having
code with grants in a supportive
utilization so they're just basically
when we have to hand back
so we can't um
go away and think we can spend those
moneys
uh down down at the bottom there's a
chance just to notice the transition
government fund reserve of 1.1 million
obviously we'll add 600 000 to that from
this year's service so hopefully we'll
start
in the building account at the start of
the next financial thursday april 2022
was never 1.7 million in our building
account to
um
allow us to balance the budgets
um yes again again of a coldly related
um issue is of course because we've been
holding government grant there is
business support grants that we've had
to pay
the council has a it's a wash for cash
basically a large chunk of that cash is
actually due back to central government
and just today before it came and
government's 2.8 million pounds back of
east africans
which has made my colleague pizza
hudson's got green and the treasury
management interesting because he never
has notice of when the government will
want the money back
generally as a rule
we will end the year of about 13 or 14
million pounds in our bank account which
is actually backed by reserves the
balance went so high initiated because
we're holding government grants that we
have not spent
and at the moment we've got four million
in green deposits at the moment it's
getting problematic to actually find
green ethical investments that meet tax
revenue management
policy at the moment we have to find it
difficult
so there is a recommendation that
internal law view integrity not the
recommendations from community resources
on the 14th of march regarding the
utilization of the increased surface
2021-22
uh have to take any questions
any questions
yes
um
yeah
the homelessness um
issue is is really alarming
if you think about it
i think we should all be
much more aware of the financial
implications the budget this council
with the um
looming
increased crisis and homes um
brought on particularly by increasing
energy prices and energy costs and all
the other high
[Music]
this strategy presented to us
i thought that was going to come this
month but i see it's coming a bit later
now
hopefully we're going to see that in may
is that right
um
[Music]
yes that report is coming to the next
committee
yeah
[Music]
on an emergency basis are we able to
talk about that or not
[Music]
the team will be advertising more
private sector
uh properties um so you will see recent
adverts going for that
um obviously we've been
discussing and seeing our the
acquisition of further through the
property
um obviously we can't go into details
around that because it was in
so there are actions being taken uh and
giant williams as i said we bring in a
more detailed report back to this
committee at your next meeting as uh
david chris alluded to the most
significant problem is
finding sustainable long-term properties
for individuals to to move into and you
live in obviously the fact that energy
prices and inflation everything else is
going to continue to cause a problem
over the
coming months
um but clearly they can't get a
sustainable tendency for somebody to
move into other temporary accommodation
they end up in that accommodation for a
short period of time and then go around
around the cir
in a cycle coming back and presented
as homeless homeless
cases again so it's it's finding a more
sustainable long-term solution which
isn't easy and it's a similar problem
being faced up and down the country
this morning i just like mentioned that
you've probably seen in the press and
that one of my constituents is looking
for a home she's got four kids she's got
a couple dogs she's been kicked out of
her house uh she's uh hanging there
until she's legal you have to get out as
you can't find anywhere anywhere and
it's it is just frightening is there
anything we could we we can do for
trying to comment on an individual
case comes ahead and i suggest if you
want some assistance come speak to janet
williams or having paige
in the team i want to go into details
about the individual case thank you
anyone else country language i see you
wanting to speak
about the vacancies actually staff
vacancies
and the pressure that that must be
causing on staff
um
can you do you know why
there is such a struggle to fill
vacancies and and is there any evidence
that some staff are leaving because of
increased workload because
we haven't got enough staff you know to
me worries made the pressure on the sun
um
there isn't any evidence of the latter
um
i i think
wage pressure
um outside of the public sector will be
having an impact
because something it's a lot easier the
private sector to
increase it increase wages and increase
price which is obviously that factor
that's
bubbled in and
increasingly the inflation rate
um obviously the public sector we more
constrained around annual pay awards so
that is a factor
um
nationally during the pandemic
i think
a lot i'm not saying that
uh but a lot of people took the
opportunity to retire
that's created vacancies uh throughout
the country and people have moved on so
we've had a number of staff who walked
on to other opportunities and then fill
in those uh vacancies which has just
proved problematic and again
not that it's uh um insurance but it's a
similar problem across uh local
government particularly um in those
um
in the markets in the the lower end of
the pay scale
where the comparat comparative pay for
supermarkets work
catering work is
quite similar or it's even higher
so you know david
is a problem uh we're having to
uh re-juggle general resources around
the teams to play gaps
um but you know as our performance shows
we are still performing well but it's
you know it's not sustainable over a
prolonged period you know that she said
that the planning scheme of other
applications still coming in and have to
be judged with within a
specified time
um
will cause problems long term
thank you sorry i know it's not a
fault an answer for a solution but yeah
i agree i mean i think i think you'll
find that
throughout the
working force even the private sector is
struggling
i mean my wife works in a pharmacist and
pharmacy and
they have a lack of pharmacies
pharmacists in there
and they've ended up closing half a day
and on several occasions
lack of bus drivers and
seems like i don't know where they've
all gone really but
they've all gone and got
even better jobs or like
steve says they retired and
that's a problem
[Music]
we have explored and we've looked
outside of the box as much as possible
with regard to the use of the new
burdens funding that we've been given in
the
new burdens funding
was the additional money given to us to
deliver
the various grants that government
requires to pay
on paper we've actually banked a lot of
that money and we're using it to
actually offset uh
in our budget elsewhere or indeed where
we're using the magnitude to show
to contribute towards showing yourself
um
[Music]
that's what i mean that that money was
was given to us
not to reward us but to actually cover
the real costs
of delivering the extra work that
government required us to do
so
i know that finding agencies start
qualified agency staff would be very
different and speak from my lead member
president on the russian bend side but
the the
agency plug plugging in
would be very difficult
my greatest concern now and we've been
touching on just now is that
the continued work level on the
remaining staff
is not sustainable
and as a result we're going to actually
hit a significant retention problem of
them that we've got
and
the spiral will get turned faster going
downhill faster
and then we really will be in an issue
have we
used that money
and i'm thinking about
incentivizing additional current staff
that we have
um where staff have not just had to work
a bit harder because of the coding but
actually have had to take on an
additional job for instance and then had
to come back to do their day job as well
uh later um
are we actually using some of this money
to recognize that in order that we hold
on to those remaining staff because
otherwise
and this is a leadership issue
um rather than a finance uh or a a money
issue
but from a leadership point of view
we've got to we cannot afford to lose
more stuff from stock and we've been
given
partially the tools with which to do it
um i'm i'm concerned that we may not
have looked at it in a broader upfront
jeff i can answer so i think what
one of the best things to say is um
if hindsight gives you a wonderful thing
um had we known at the start of the
pandemic
that we were going to have to pay out
somewhere in the order of 50 million
pounds
administer 20 different uh grant schemes
then looking back now if we knew that
right at the start then we probably
would have done things differently in
terms of seeking to employ additional
resources
but for every one of the
grand schemes that came out they were
announced last minute
we had very little information about
what they would entail and what they
would um
resource i get a job i'm going to
interrupt i get that and i'm not i'm not
asking you to look at it with hindsight
i'm saying but let us look at the here
and now and that's right it's going to
come on to us just running through okay
um the kind of history um because we've
as i said
previously we've had 20 different grand
schemes
which we've had to administer
with all of these schemes you need staff
that are properly trained uh have the
knowledge and experience i'm picking
them up
this week to start next week doesn't
work um that's why i said in hindsight
had we known this this was going on for
a long time we probably would have
recruited differently
as david said what we've done with our
existing staff is utilize their
experience so if we move them from one
job to another then they would have been
uh paid what what they would for that
role so that that's been
done
i'm not quite sure what you
what you mean then about incentivizing
um because it's difficult to incentivize
individuals all staff across the council
have had to do
and pick up additional work from our
waste and recycling crews who have
picked up extra uh refuse extra
recycling to the planning team housing
benefits team it's across the board
staff have performed at a higher level
within within reason i accept that but
you've got certain areas of the staff
which is
you know i mean that's
within revs and benz and i mean it's an
ongoing situation but as you as you know
we are
there are discussions going on with the
department of work and pensions at the
moment where we are in danger or have
been in danger of in effect being put
into what
other um
categories would be called special
measures because we we are getting so
behind now we've taken those staff
and we've said
okay stop what you're doing
and um work
full time on the the delivery of the
um business support grant or whatever
the various grant of the day was coming
from government
and but then
they've still got their normal day job
in addition to that so we're not talking
about a little bit of extra dog we're
actually actually got a section of our
workforce who
in effect their work has doubled
and
the
impact is that we're now in an area of
reputational risk
because our performance in that area is
not good
in that
we are getting so far behind
and that is performance
and
in an area where the slower we are to um
address people's problems the more
wound up and upset and our rate the
complainant or the applicant gets so the
whole thing becomes
a nasty thing and i
i'm
i i'm
it's easy
to have turned out i say well everyone's
worked very much harder in this
difficult time and therefore we can do
nothing for nobody but
if we start to lose more staff from this
very specialist area for councillors to
to train somebody
in
council tax
processing takes six months before they
can fly america to train somebody on
other areas of revenue and benefits it
takes 12 months before they can fly on
their own so
it's a it's a very skilled thing
and
if i was in private business
i'd throw money at the problem to keep
the people in
jobs who i cannot afford to lose
because if i do i'll go under and i'm
worried that we're not actually reacting
to this in a leadership way
well we are we are trapped with that
that's an area where we recruited
david
yeah i know what we've tried to recruit
we also try to um
one of those people
um with lots of errors and um
that kind of kind of washed that really
too so there's no easy solution
um you cannot that's these will lose you
can't create a housing benefit obviously
it's also not without being money it's
not a particularly attractive gig for
somebody
you know
and we've got the constraints of
the you know we're on um the green book
the local authority pay so we you know
we can only go put our salaries up after
the the green book but we know we're
vastly concerned you know what how did
we need to stop getting more you know
the council that's rebate that's just
come but that's just coming about at a
really opportune time at a time when
uh councils
were just thinking perhaps the the end
of the pandemic could come and now
they've probably got the biggest piece
of work we've had absolutely to be
honest that's probably the biggest piece
of work we've had through the entire
pandemic watch just come back to this
energy thing and that's just the misuse
of the calcite system for
inappropriate use really
so yeah so you know we can't just target
those up and
throw money at
a single group of staff if that's not
possible we will try and we are trying
to recruit additional resources to that
team and taking measures to ensure that
the backlog is brought down
two separate things i fully fully get
the recruitment problems and and i
understand that entirely a the just lack
of applicants and secondly the lack of
suitable applicants and and then the
issues trading them um
retention
of them that we've already got is a is a
completely different
uh
management or leadership area and
i'm
unconvinced at the moment that we've
done enough to retain
those that we've got and
if we don't we're in real trouble
that's your laws you have something to
say uh
yeah yes thank you chair i'm not on this
committee but i i can't help but want to
um counter this tantric
[Music]
this is ongoing of course our leadership
team and uh i'm sure steve and his
management team are really aware of
these problems
and they're constantly looking at ways
of
um capturing it but you can't
they're not in the position saying wow
that that particular officer is doing
terrific work will give him an impact
extra increment i mean the whole system
of just four pieces then
but please all chancellors be aware that
i mean our leadership
work endless hours with the officers
trying their best to address this
thank you
thank you
silent references
to a
burden fund didn't really develop that
was that something you were saying which
could be
querying whether you used
this
that nonverdance funding is funding his
club section 31 that's received from
government when they impose a new burden
upon us so
when they have the business support
grants various guises they'd say
you've got to administer 20 million
pounds of business support grants we
recognize that's additional workload for
you they do some calculation provide us
with grant funding that's one of the
contributing factors to our surpluses
about 380 000 and what we're saying is
without various chances of funding for
those transit work they've had to do
new burdens funding that's our section
31 grant that's contributed to transfer
as i've said this council of newton's
alluded to we've largely absorbed that
within this existing people in steve
stone because of the benefit of
hindsight we do nothing different also
because the work that needs to be done
needs to be done by people who actually
know the air particularly the business
rates
a little bit on the housing benefits
with um cancer support and also within
finance you know that the easy knowledge
we have
you know we have had temporary people in
now we've had recruits we did at the
track and trace members of the lady who
did the track and trade thing so the new
burdens funding that the council
movement is referring to is grant
funding we've had to do additional work
and i think well for counseling or
working council newton's
and i'm pretty [ __ ] saying that we
could have used that money to pay people
for our retention issues
thanks ventura holston
right um
first i think as i'm not a member of
this committee but i am part of uh from
your
council's deputy leader
and in the absence of the leader i feel
i must
respond to some of the issues that have
been raised
i congratulate councillor newton in his
new leadership role for getting his head
around a lot of the facts and figures
that haven't really been debated
to any extent at
scrutiny meetings before
we are all very aware of the challenges
of staff and recruitment
um and we are also in endless dialogue
about the best ways to manage our
resources
so it's not something new
to leadership and
the chief exec and the heads of service
that are actually coping with these
issues
to incentivize people to actually
perform
is about creating a good working
environment
and again i congratulate torridge for
having a place where people want to be
working
so that's one point
they are looking at a balancing
home working opportunities and working
in office space so again
there are a different range of
approaches to retaining staff there are
staff who don't want to work at home who
want to be in the office
um
the issue for me is to
when we have
counselling you can open these comments
about us being close to being in special
measures
i think that's
really perhaps needs some clarification
because of our performance times and
delivery of our benefits services
i'm not disputing the fact that they are
not as good as they should be
but there are extenuating and mitigating
circumstances
so we do need to balance this out and
act proportionately we are not in the
commercial sector
we can't just give somebody a bonus
payment
because the unions will be down on this
like a ton of bricks and as
our section 151 officer has reported to
you we have the green book which
determines how we can pay and we won't
start
so
there are constraints
but i can tell you we've been trying to
consider every possibility
for recognizing and supporting the staff
that we employ
and we realize that they are a very very
valuable
resource
my concerns
issues are are additional
responsibilities that i think will be
coming to us
with regard to housing ukrainian
refugees
and the additional responsibilities that
will be properly directed to
district and county councils
now i haven't got the full details about
this
but i'm sure in the days to come we will
be hearing a lot more
and we need to be taking that into
consideration because households
generosities are housing people for six
months
what happens at the end of that six
months
and what uh
responsibilities will we have as a local
authority
in finding accommodation where we've
already got a housing crisis
so i think we need to really be upping
our game on this and we really need to
be talking about it
my last comment sorry sorry i've been
sitting here listening
is with regard to something on um
i think it's page 16 of the qbr with
regard to the housing benefit you see
the support scheme
and
i'm part of the working group of that
and it actually states that
reduce it's under reduced health
inequalities while promoting active
and healthy lifestyles
implementation of a new council tax
support scheme now
work started and we have
met and
i was under the impression and i want
some clarification on this please that
this we were working towards introducing
this scheme for the next
financial year for
so that we'd be delivering this
for what will it be 23 24. it now says
scheme by march 24.
now i'm concerned that it seems to have
slipped a year
and i should have asked
the two consecutive authority that it
jumped out at me on the page
okay
yeah my understanding is it should be
first of april
2023
that's my understanding and that the
there's a company we engaged to do some
modeling for us within the next eight
weeks i don't know if definitive works i
suspect that might be inside though all
right thank you very
sense of much
because we've had
year-on-year delay because of the
extra work that our benefits felt can be
done
so at least that is on track
but i do urge
scrutiny to talk and when we get the
housing strategy to make sure that we
are taking into
consideration all the challenges that we
are facing
i need to be
listening to
the comments and interested in listening
to david with his presentation and all
in his hand i've always liked people who
all right
when we didn't allow anything for the
1.75
wage increase we did that at northern
we put 2 percent in our budget
and so
but that's fair enough
[Music]
wage increase i think really anybody
would have realized there'd definitely
be some kind of evidence
but getting back to this thing that
counselor newton
the point that councilman has done
housing benefits and i knew the only new
yesterday morning i was subbing on me
and i printed all the
qbr
report out in december
i had looked at it on screen when it
came out a couple of weeks back
flipped with them
but that does spread it revs and
benefits that
you know we're now
10 weeks handling and that's not
acceptable
and what occurred to me was how we
shifted staff from there to do other
jobs
as councilman alluded to perhaps for
help
and we shouldn't be doing that
to extract from anywhere else not from
reds and benefits when when we're at 10
weeks dealing with claims
and the other thing are we have we got
enough in staffing in revzilla or are we
dead short how many are we short
but when you look at the figures here
that our top year-to-date target is 20
days
and and in this report it's 51.3
you know
it did not stand out that
i don't actually believe any staff were
taken out of housing benefits to do some
business support grants the actual
business support grants
to be honest was largely known by two
people in business rates with the
support of finance colleagues and we've
knocked them plus colleagues for the
discretionary grant schemes
have we still got another scout working
from home
and is it efficient
as is it as efficient as being in the
office because
there's lots of stories in the press
saying in many instances it doesn't work
i'm all for flexibility for
staff in any business
but i just wonder because very often
you're in the office down leather back
there's nobody asked
the phone
and not even yet sometimes don't even
answer phone
i mean have we still a large proportion
at home working
[Music]
right yeah it is but it's an extra some
stuff working on some staff are within
the office i think the the housing
benefit team are predominantly working
in the office they are
customer facing
um
the in terms of the the number of staff
the number of staff in the team
uh
similar to planning i guess was the the
right level um pre-pandemic because if
you if you go back the
stats show that they were performing
highly
um i think as as we've alluded to
different things have occurred
throughout the pandemic
and if you think of the
david alluded to the the recent council
tax rebate scheme which was announced
some weeks ago then all of a sudden i
will be paid through the the council tax
system and that's nothing nothing at all
heating cost is nothing at all to do
with local councils or the council tax
system and that has to be administered
and the announcement is that we paid in
april so we kind of on the back foot
with some of these things all the time
um
you know we have been trying to recruit
to posts within the team but that is
proven difficult i think we've recently
recruited one or two new members of
staff who are now being trained so
you know that will bring things back on
i mean are we only five people short six
three
[Music]
[Music]
short i think that's the
the thing and
in terms of the council tax reduction
scheme but
again
the implementation of that will help the
team in terms of uh the number of uh
cases go to the system
council approved um
an mit system
uh where a lot of that work will be done
online so that will improve the
throughput and the
working of the system to a highest price
i mean when you can
compare revenue benefits then with
planning
and planning
colossal increase in applications in
planning yet the performance figures are
still very good
better than target
comparing
pairs they're completely different
systems well they might be different
systems but i'm talking about the
performance of that department which
has been usually as you know
the applications have been incredible at
rising them
so they've had an awful extra workload
to deal with
and
i mean i think steve that performance
holds up i mean steve's point i think
it's still some validity i mean
i'll
i want to be modest that my finance team
has performed remarkably well
uh knowledge repair inviting on time we
got all the government returns we've
done very well in terms of audit reports
etc
but i've been blessed that i've kept the
same team for now four and a half years
i've got experienced people
know what they're doing motivated
and i've been looking that i've kept the
same team for now if i'd lost any one of
those people i could have not been able
to recruit
i don't know i can't handle how to say
that i've been able to deliver the
service my team has done
we seem to have been relatively
fortunate we've had issues maybe about
three four years ago and we had a
massive shortage of planners and we were
running back on planning applications
pre-packed pre-pandemic lesser levels
we seemed to be relatively functional
we've retained a lot of planners
recently about the turnover that we've
won previously has been so sometimes it
can just be the turnover of staff
thank you
i mean one of the implications of this
very long delay processing mounting
benefit on people's
[Music]
financial aspect is sometimes it is a
delay in processing a change of
circumstances
be treated as an la local authority
error rather than
that plain terror if the claimant has
told us the change of circumstances we
continue to pay the house
higher rate
if that gets too large
then we can lose additional funding
under the subsidy that we've penalized
by the government doesn't want us to do
make states i don't know if the
individuals have never heard of any
individual being
um
made homeless as a result of delay
housing depending sure that
and really have a
constructive debate about it when we
know
more about the subject because
i think at
this point we're just going around and
around in circles a little bit now so
plus
this is something scrutiny ought to
be scrutinizing in the proper way
um i don't know what other data think
about that and what the state thinks
yeah
um chairs are going to suggest we report
back the
is happy with that yeah
yes
any mother any other other questions
other questions we do okay
right we got recommendation there i
think this is just for noting it's not
for any vote is it
so it's just for noting counselors
so you're happy that we note this report
here
recommendation there
[Music]
you read there is that okay yeah right
we'll move on then
the questions
um
okay on page 39.
you know we've got those there
uh first one is from um
mr harper
um
are you happy with the answer there mr
barbara
good thank you
the next one is for again from
mr harper
yes okay with that
next one again is
from mr harper
are you happy with that
answer
yeah does the cost interaction improve
the ranges as well
that includes everything that actually
applies to the barriers
and the question was
using the borrowers as a cost yes yes it
does absolutely everything is included
the rangers the uh people who take the
income
from attendance
right okay
my answer is the second part as well yes
notice that we've actually got a problem
with the security tool
can you tell us a little bit more about
that
is that a design fault or is that a
[Music]
see the
indications in discussion with the
construction company to see the
resolution so i have any more details
than that in fact that indicates a snap
as opposed as opposed to a design
i suspect it's a design problem with the
sound yeah that's that's how i read it
it was a snapping issue
we'll ask sean to confirm that
and i also understand maybe other design
objects as well
perhaps that might come back as well
okay
next one again is
um
back to you mr harper
that happened with the next one right
and then we go on to the local economy
um
[Music]
a joint one this started yeah that's
good
both happy
yes i understand that
yes
yes okay
you know we have some seaweed
[Music]
we haven't gotten
is
we'll see if something can
come back to you well we know
there are a tv forum
in the valley um but
you know they've
notified us but they've not said where
they've ever landed or where they
[Music]
again you okay with that one
if this is the strategy yes it's now run
out completely from the media strategy
you have you do seem to be bumping along
this one i know that
strategy and joint strategy between
north carolina district council less
it just seems and i understand that
things have actually changed
we don't really have a strategy apart
from what we've had in the past
yeah
sorry yeah obviously
what it is is we've been talking about
this
i've raised this a number of times now
and this is over a year ago we actually
had the thing that said john vernon was
actually
writing the strategy up for um
if the economy is the number one issue
or number one
objective for the council
we haven't even got a strategy
that that's a concern i think it sort of
goes on with what we said before
yeah so the the response is it's name i
appreciate it hasn't got a date on there
so obviously we produce the recovery
prospectus
that covers the three-year period and
as it says will form the basis of the
net economic stronghold we need to get
from chris
um some background details around time
in some things
okay you're happy
well
no no no you're
happy with that
yeah okay
thank you yeah i would just like to say
that i mean i really appreciate
the um honest
um line at the bottom that says
apologies overall this strategic action
is not on target um i just
will probably
understand completely i just feel
extremely frustrated about it that you
know we've had the play strategy
together to put together and it's not on
target and i'm not having to go
at any offices or anything about it
because i appreciate
the financial
um pressures and as
um possibly in the future increased
financial pressures through homelessness
etc but we said we were going to do
something and we obviously are not on
track
and i appreciate from adrian's point of
view incredibly difficult i i do i don't
see how you're supposed to get victoria
park
started
on time without your budget to do it i
know we've discussed that before
but um yeah i'm just um thank you for
the answer
um please note my frustration
thank you
um
over to you again thanks for laughing
oh yes thank you thank you for
a very detailed explanation thank you
very much
[Music]
and it also comes back to a question i
asked earlier on the earmark deserves
that no section 215 meant being spent
and the uh
the enforcement officer is confident
that as well there's no wonder nothing's
been done
[Music]
yeah
okay
i
i don't know really because
why the you know the
the money hasn't been spent
i guess that nothing's really come up
perhaps
or perhaps they're over
right okay
um that's
well i mean it's not like catch your
hands raising this you can't discuss
what could be done about this
as i understand the importance of
processes they're sort of categorizing
cases in terms of importance is that
what works
i haven't got any information on
enforcement
so we can note the questions on the
action just
yes
um
that's a wider
connection with this enforcement and
that
the ability to go down the enforcement
group
serves as a deterrent
on others to comply
um
where we end up with
an increasing number of
enforcement caseload
and
as a result
percentage-wise fewer and fewer cases
where enforcement action is actually
taken or can be taken or or can be
followed through because we know that
enforcement is incredibly time consuming
will always be contentious um and there
will be challenges etcetera etcetera and
there will be on the ground issues and
that all takes his amount of time and
effort invariably that is not being done
and
out in the rural world of planning at
the moment
i know that the word
and the feeling on the street is
actually the risk of enforcement is
reducing because torridge basically
are not able to cope with it and
therefore the likelihood of people
deciding deliberately
to flaunt planning rules um uh because
they think they won't get caught or even
if they are picked up it won't be
followed through is increasing so i
would just make a comment that um
in in this wherever that you know
there's cause and effect and um uh that
that is what
the downtrack um um
[Music]
consequence of this situation where
in my ward there's three enforcement
and there's no
doesn't seem to be any teeth to it so
it's it just seems to be on good with
one of its three and a half years
with a very very upset local population
who say what are you doing about it yeah
and um
um
so
all right well thanks for the comment
reference
[Music]
yes
okay all right i can do that
right
any more questions
right we're going to
number nine
there's your service update steve
um okay thanks um so we kind of now
within
a matter of days i guess before the end
of the contract
so
matthew wright our leisure operations
managers kind of dealing with all the
finer details of the handover from 1610
to active torridge
we'll
shortly this week be issuing some comms
information
to our members and customers
so providing them the necessary details
for this handover process
so we'll go into too much detail and
kind of broadcast that in advance of all
that information going out obviously i'm
sure remember some members will be aware
we still have problems at toronto pool
uh and so far as it's still
closed some of the work
hadn't been scheduled but
due to
coverage
contractors not being available that's
been delayed i believe the the
boilerworks are scheduled for
next week the
the problem around the the leak uh in
the pool is still being investigated
um i understand the the side of the
school's been
excavated to sort by the source of the
problem
and so outside of things is still
ongoing
um so everything else is is moving
moving along
recruitment
has been
um
in that area has been relatively good
um i know that's got a couple of gaps
which we've had to go back to the market
on but we've got sufficient staff to
operate the service across the site so
that's positive
in terms of outstanding maintenance work
required from 1610 they've done
a considerable amount of work in
getting the the repairs maintenance shed
duels completed uh we were due to catch
up with 1610 last week but that had to
be delayed to do some other outstanding
matters so we'll be doing that very
shortly
to have that kind of final underwear
and social everything um is on track uh
for handover and opening there there'll
inevitably be
um some period short period of closure
between uh taking equipment out and
putting equipment back in
doing some deep cleaning and painting et
cetera but that all that information can
be uh put together in our comms messages
this week right good
sounding good catch your hand yeah i
think thank you very much for that i
think one of the strongest indicators
that forage means business
as far as the northern pool is concerned
will be to
spruce up the outside of the building
because at the moment it looks really
horrible covered in mold
and that would be i think a good signal
chair there's very various pieces of
work scheduled to make the properties
look um more aesthetically pleasing to
the eye both internal and external okay
and i suppose there'll be some sort of
press release and things like that
okay
happy
right you just note that report
i'm going on to the grounds maintenance
service
okay thank you
sorry i'm sorry
[Music]
morning committee
this is from
um richard hayes
the
[Music]
appreciation services manager he sends
his apologies he's on leave this week so
he sent me an update to um to provide uh
the committee with
uh so i will read from my screen and
i've got some notes um from a colleague
as well
so he's saying four staff including the
supervisors will be transferring from
tivoli
originally he was supposed to be five
but one has decided not to come over
the other advert is out for a
replacement
in addition there will be two summer
seasonals to assist with grass cutting
during the growing season
then he moves on to machines all
machines have been ordered and will be
delivered on the 29th of this month and
will be stored at victoria park
he's also purchased two machines from
tivoli one to cover the sports ground
and the qriket pitch
there was no point buying
a new
and they've had a very good deal
two new trailers have also been acquired
two transit fans are on order
um but there um are delayed due to the
short supply of vehicles as a backup um
he's got a short-term plan
to hire
two two
two vehicles to get the machines around
in the rural areas
yeah he's also going to borrow
[Music]
a van from parking services um who are
due to replace two fans shortly he's
going to use them in one room so he can
understand the service demands going
forward before making a final decision
the depot so that they're moving to the
uh buildings in victoria park um the
poverty team will uh make a start on the
different next week
to make it secure and improve the
welfare facilities uh the tivoli staff
have already started clearing it out
including including the greenhouses
there
software
um
this is my other bit so we we have
got some new software so the team can
operate we've imported the data from
torridge
they've got a conference call today with
the software providers to make sure that
it all
whereas that is all lined up to our
cutting maintenance schedule
they've got training booked in on the
second and third of april for the new
staff when they come across
um
the trees there's a local qualified
qtra inspection that has been contracted
to do this work
um which is the same company that that
does north devon's uh trees
uh the plan is to have two grass cutting
teams on one
[Music]
during the summer season
during the winter we'll cut it down to
force that so be very busy dealing with
the bushes shrubs and the winter
maintenance
he's happy to
answer any questions at the meeting if
anybody has it but it's confident that
it's all ready for handover at the end
of the month and until the start on the
1st of april
good news thanks for having me
yeah thanks for that john i had a long
chat with uh
richard last week because i went in as
leading them with western new cycling
and possibly another league member for
the this new service when it comes in
house from april and he will show me all
the work that all the work that's gone
into this has been a colossal amount of
work undertaking
the trees that john just mentioned for
what
we had
because tibet was supposed to be
nothing's been done with the trees for
years not proper pollarding or cottasin
or looking after them
and he's got everything on the screen
there on the computer
i mean as you probably all know richard
is so fairer
incredibly thorough and i'm very
impressed with everything that's on
board as along with all the rest of
these
his um
duties
because he's got an awful waste of
recycling really and the harbour but
yeah
he's given me a lot of confidence that
this would be
a seamless transition from april to
taking it back in house and
long overdue that would take this
service back in that section
um the security issues at victoria park
that
there because
we have one break even more than
one down there but that's in hand as
well
as john moody too
so yeah
i'm very pleased with
how it's progressing thank you
thank you
thank you thank you john uh i'm
uh hoping that uh now that we're in
house with this that the
gardens are gonna look much better what
they have done
is is this gonna actually you know
happen because
tivoli have been rubbish
doing the the lovely flower beds they've
all gone in victoria park i always think
of victoria park because it's where i
live so i don't know what the other
parks are like but um you know are they
gonna
make our gardens look pretty again with
lots of plants going on
i've got to be honest
i can't answer that all i can say is
i'll we'll find out and get you to kind
of um email around i mean they have been
looking disgusting gardens and there's
no work down there happening at the
minute i guess that because they're very
busy doing other things but really they
should be like turning over the gardens
getting them ready for the spring and
summer
when richard did speak to me about his
uh last week he was confident that the
service that will be provided and
similar to what councillor leathers just
said we'll be better than
we've had in the past so but i'll
find out a little bit more about his
plans for the flower beds and etc
thank you
uh yes um yeah i totally agree
[Music]
the workforce is actually at the moment
less than normally
a northern part fully occupied the whole
time
um
and i'm afraid that we're going to find
perhaps the same situation around
maintenance
other aspects in torture now it's
i know it's but usually
sometimes becomes a fair minimum surface
just cutting the grounds alone is
and i think
the organization is something that has
been lacking with that stamp yeah
they've been able to get away with
murder in lots of locations not doing
what they were contracted to do
but it is a case really to suck it and
see to an
we'll take this stuff off if it needs
another member of staff down the road
that'll have to be budgeted more and
it'll be accommodated but which is quite
happy with
with what what he started
was here it goes but i think that's
probably right
john yeah yeah can i just come back to
green totally with councillor and to say
that my team and i t have been working
with richard and his team and what
they've got now with this software is a
really good
one which they've never had with
previously they've got it
mapped they've got it scheduled so that
the data that they're going to have to
start with will make actually the
delivery easier because it'll be more
controlled
so i'm really hope hopeful that actually
richard will have all the data and
information he needs with with the guys
having it on their devices as well
knowing exactly what they're supposed to
be doing when
so i think the control and the kind of
the
the information
should be a lot better than it ever was
so really hoping that you know there's
been a lot of work between 19 and with
richard's lot um kelly i know has
inspected every one of the play sites to
make sure they've got all the equipment
on the system properly done as well so
you know the information there will will
help start delivering the service but
there will be a lot of learning points
along the way as well
all right
everyone happy
[Music]
how's your daughter
is replaced
and not just like as in in western
degree
we have red and white tape
on two pieces of equipment
are they to be reinstalled or replaced
or is that just something that
will remain outstanding into your budget
no i
i think that's
probably outside of that rematch
of the greatest maintenance they
they don't do anything to that do they
i think that they will be inspecting
them
i don't know about the replacement or
the restraining of that
that's a completely separate matter yeah
i think it is yes
yes is it possible i could have an
answer to the question of equipment that
becomes uh that dangerous redundancy or
physics
coming out
i think it depends um it depends on how
it feeds over the strategy so i can't
say yes it will be replaced or not to
the stage
when we when we um
together externally
there was i remember a
big debate at the time
as to whether the
play strategy should be
should have its own budget
ring fence budget
or whether it would be funded generally
from the
the wider maintenance
[Music]
the decision was not to give it a
dedicated budget
which with hindsight um
as we've seen with victoria park
and again perhaps that this question
also um
it it creates these dilemmas yeah just
from a historical point of view
that there was a debate
uh in the production of that strategy
uh as to whether actually there was a
dedicated budget
and the decision at the end of the day
was not to have a ringtone budget
or something
um costumes and things like that at this
point
cheers
[Music]
and make a decision about whether to
replace or a name yes okay
so yes that's got to be moved at the
time um i think we'll move on that's
just noted that that report that
john's did so we move on to the
um forward plan
anybody
any suggestions
catch your hands yeah i was just
wondering what's going to happen to the
s3 specialty because we had a
working group on it and
that's a very good question and i can't
remember what the process was i got a
feeling it was going to go to
the heart i remember
you know what we were waiting for was
economic development to actually do a
strategy for the uh yesterday thank you
it's going to be in next this year's or
next year's business plan that's quite
right yeah thank you
okay
anybody wants to add anything to the
forward plan
well will that come on forward plan at
some point yes it'll be strategically i
guess it will yes yeah but it hasn't the
work hasn't been started yet so i think
it might be some time before that's
that's sad
okay
hopefully anybody's suggestions right
we'll move on then well
uh we haven't gotten the
part two so that's the end of the
meeting
thank you very much
and enjoy the day